foreign
[Music]
s out there Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist I have with me
for this explainer video Ray Kurzweil
one of the largest exponents in
Civilization of the singularity what it
is where it's coming from where is it
going why is it good is it bad is it
ugly Ray
please
tell us what is a singular you wrote
about this in 2005 the singularity is
near and then you've got a book coming
out in 2023 The Singularity is nearer
part you sound a little like a cult
leader you know the end is coming join
my group so tell us what is the
singularity
a couple of steps the first step is for
computers to actually match what humans
can do so we're not there yet Turing
actually has a very good test for
equality Alan Turing yeah yeah and he uh
defined that in 1950
and we have that in mind just to be
clear so the movie The imitation game
was basically a profile of his work
especially uh decoding uh the the the
Nazi
uh uh
messages which was very key that was
actually the third computer that I was
ever created right general purpose
computer okay so go on I interrupted
continue
so I I actually predicted that we would
pass the Turing test by 2029 and I
predicted that in 1999
and AI experts were dubious about that
they held an International Conference
based on my prediction
uh they took the very first poll of AI
experts and the experts were saying it's
uh yes it will happen but it's going to
take a hundred years and actually 20
percent of the AI experts thought it
would never happen and the and the
Turing test is if I remember from my
early Computing days it's you have this
interface and you have a conversation
with that interface and if you cannot
tell
that the thing is not human then
whatever that is it has passed the
Turing test is that a fair exactly okay
so if you really can't tell the
difference the computer has passed the
Turing test now we realize now that in
order to pass the Turing test it's
actually going to have to dumb itself
down
well I mean take for example playing go
which is it's one of thousands of skills
that humans have this is the ancient
Chinese game which is way more complex
and challenging than chess
yes or take chess I mean if a computer
can do it it goes way past what humans
can do
uh so
and it's going to do that in every field
so it's not like you just know go or not
I mean there's many different levels of
playing and that's true of everything
that we do
and so so it'll have to dumb itself down
otherwise you would be able to tell it's
a computer because it's so much better
than you at it not because it hasn't
reached your level that's like a crazy
inverse uh invocation of the Turing test
yeah yeah and there's a lot of art to
doing that but uh
so
but we we create this tool basically to
enhance ourselves I mean we want to
advance technology
uh and so we created uh these machines
it can go way past us
uh the way to do that is to actually
bring that a that intelligence into
ourselves
and during the 2030s we're going to be
able to enhance our own intelligence by
bringing AI into ourselves so it's not
just going to be humans versus machines
they're going to be together and we're
going to be more uh Advanced because
we'll have ai inside us I can hold a
smartphone in my hand which gives me
access to the everything yes it does it
does that somewhat
they're just not the same thing except I
don't it doesn't require neurosurgery
for me to gain access to the well you
don't have to use neurosurgery I mean
there's ways to to do this you have ways
you have you have to do it with your
fingers we have ways
[Laughter]
um I've I've done some reading about
Nanobots is that ready for prime time or
not no but I believe it will be ready in
the 2030s
and these are small
they're basically small machines that
live in your brain and communicate with
the internet
exactly and so that's going to make it
smarter
now if you look at my price performance
of computation it continues and we can
actually talk about what these future
computers will look like so this is this
is computations per second
per dollar
right it's a constant dollar constant
dollar and that's been something that
has grown exponentially over the past
hundred years basically yeah exactly
okay
so ultimately we'll be able to amplify
our intelligence a million fold
because we only have so much ability to
put things together in our physical
brain
uh so we'll go way past that so it's one
thing today when we think of smart
people they just know a lot of stuff
right but anyone plus a smartphone knows
a lot of stuff so I think the real value
of intelligence when we think about it
and use the term is your ability to
solve a problem that no one could solve
before when you say we amplify our
intelligence by a million folder pick
any Factor are we going to be able to
solve problems that were previously
intractable
I mean we're doing that now with AI
uh
uh and solving really key problems that
are important for medicine and so on uh
that humans would never be able to do
so once that's inside us we'll be able
to solve problems that we couldn't solve
before all right so what you're saying
is that these these apocalyptic AI
storytellers that have done this in TV
shows and in film
that's AI disembodied from us somehow
achieving Consciousness all right and
then turning on us violating one of the
you know the asimovian
Laws of Robotics right you can't turn on
your creator but if it's part of us then
we just everyone is just simply enhanced
is that is that where you see this is
going so that's a that's a very positive
outlook on this
but you know we get to a point where
we're enhanced so much that it's hard to
imagine what that will be like
uh so that's why we use the term
Singularity I mean Singularity you know
started you took my word I just want you
to know we had my black holes are
singularities and you took it just I
want you to atone for that at some point
in all fairness there's a mathematical
singularities that predate that before
and then physics and then we in
astrophysics and now you all put it into
Computing but go on
physics took it because you had
something that had a gravity that's
beyond uh what we can normally
uh occur so if somebody has enough
gravity everything falls into it nothing
comes down black hole Singularity we got
it okay now you took the word
and you're referring to you're referring
to a point in cultural time in in space
where everything after that will be
different from everything before exactly
exactly
uh because we'll have multiplied our
intelligence a million involvements very
hard to imagine what that would be like
and if everyone has it multiplied by a
million fold
it would be hard to wonder how we got
that far
without that intelligence
if you look back we wouldn't want to go
back
foreign
you wouldn't want to I so I would look
forward to Solutions
today to what things were like in the
past
uh is already Amplified by an
intelligence using owners and phones and
so on right right right
well this is quite the quite the
scenario you're painting here so you so
it's so just to put some closure on this
in your judgment
the greatest fears that AI experts bring
to the table are unfounded because
that's simply not the direction it's
going to go
I mean there are dangers I mean you can
imagine weapons
Amplified by AI which could be quite
dangerous
uh so I'm not saying there's no dangers
um
but I I am optimistic that we can make
positive use of this
uh provided it's part of who we are
rather than something external to us
yeah exactly and this idea that there's
a Consciousness if we're a million times
smarter are we a million times more
conscious
uh do are we a million times more moral
are there other these intangibles here
well I would I would say so because I
mean if you look at I mean I believe
animals higher animals or conscious
but are we more conscious than a mouse
when the mouse
you know keeps its own uh
wants to continue its own uh
uh wants to stay alive it has a lot of
the things that we have but they're not
quite as intelligent as we honestly we
don't think about those as much as we
think about humans uh how about an
insect I mean they have they also
maintain their own posture in the world
but they're not quite as intelligent as
humans
um so for more until more creative more
intelligent have more memory uh we will
be more conscious and by whatever that
means it'll it's a certainty I guess
whatever that'll be
well Ray I hope you know you've also
written a lot no time to get into it
here but you've also written a lot of on
longevity and living forever and what
how machines will a machine body
interface will Empower that so I hope
you live long enough
to see everything you're predicting so
that we can cheer you or mock you for
what you have said I hope we both live
long enough to see that so Ray thanks
for spending just these few minutes with
Star Talk an explainer video on the
singularity from the man himself Greg
kurzweiler
until next time Neil deGrasse Tyson keep
looking up
thank you